when people think of the highest paying
jobs in the world they generally think
of top executives and this makes sense
given that people like sunder piche and
tim cook often pull in over a hundred
million dollars per year but there's
actually one job that pays even higher
and that's being a hedge fund manager
the top hedge fund managers aren't just
billionaires but they literally make
billions every single year
in 2021 the top paid hedge fund manager
was ironically ken griffin from citadel
who pulled in a total of 2.5 billion
dollars
considering this insane income you would
think that these guys are the next
warren buffett but this isn't exactly
true
at least with top executives they
generally create a lot more value for
shareholders than their paid themselves
for example since tim cook became ceo
apple's market cap has grown over 2
trillion dollars so it's understandable
that tim cook is paid so much but with
hedge fund managers their performance is
generally not only mediocre but they
often don't even beat the market ken
griffin citadel for example grew a solid
26 in 2021 this sounds really good until
you realize that the s p 500 itself grew
26.89
in 2021
so ken basically only had average
performance yet he received the highest
salary in the entire world
so why are hedge fund managers paid so
much when their performance is at best
mediocre
to understand why hedge fund managers
are paid so much we have to first
understand what type of person even
invests in a hedge fund in the first
place in terms of qualifications
generally you have to be an accredited
investor and you have to be willing to
invest a minimum amount of capital to be
part of a given hedge fund citadel for
example requires that you have 10
million 000 investable assets to join
their funds
considering this the average investor in
hedge funds are billionaires and
institutional investors like banks
pension funds and retirement funds and
often the top priority for these guys is
not capital growth but rather risk
minimization here's the thing if you're
a billionaire your company and or
investments have been demolishing the
market for several years if not decades
take jeff bezos for example since amazon
went public their stock has grown from
two dollars a share to about three
thousand dollars a share today after
accounting for stock splits
if we annualize this return we get an
average annual return of over 35 percent
now that might not sound like a lot
given that the s p 500 already averages
seven to eight percent per year but when
you compound this growth things get
wacky extremely quickly for example if
you average 8 per year for 25 years you
end up with a solid 7.34 x return but if
you average 35 per year for 25 years you
end up with a 5 500 x return considering
this someone like jeff bezos isn't
trying to maximize returns when they
invest in a hedge fund they're trying to
minimize risk this becomes even more
important when you consider that most
billionaires have their entire net worth
tied up with one maybe two companies but
wait a minute how exactly does a hedge
fund even minimize risk in the first
place
well one of their risk mitigation
strategies is in their name hedging if
you're not familiar with what hedging is
it's basically buying insurance on all
of your positions by also betting the
opposite of what you think is going to
happen for example let's say i'm a
massive fan of tesla and i think it's
going to 10x from where it's at right
now
so i go ahead and invest 10 dollars into
tesla if i wanted to hedge this position
i would spend an additional one dollar
on betting that tesla will go down
there's multiple ways to do this from
shorting to buying options to performing
equity swaps but the specifics don't
really matter all you need to know is
that this one dollar position goes up in
value if tesla stock goes down now if my
initial thesis was right and tesla does
10x i'll lose the one dollar that i bet
against tesla but my initial 10
investment would grow to 100 meaning
that i still profit 89
on the other hand if my thesis is wrong
and tesla has in value my initial
investment would go down to five dollars
but the one dollar that i bet on tesla
might have grown to three or four
dollars meaning that i'm left with a
total of eight or nine dollars in this
case i only lost twenty to thirty
percent of my initial investment while
the average tesla investor lost a full
fifty percent and this is really the
core of what hedge fund managers are
paid to do
[Music]
every hedge fund has a beta value
depending on how much the given fund
hedges their positions if a fund has a
beta value of 1 that means that their
positions will perform exactly in line
with the general market if the s p 500
goes up five percent the hedge fund will
also make five percent and vice versa
if a fund has a beta value over one this
means that the fund is more volatile
than the general market if the market
grows five percent such a fund may grow
ten percent but the thing to note is
that if the market drops five percent
such a fund will lose ten percent while
there are some funds out there with the
beta over one and this is by no means
the average hedge fund a fund could also
have a negative beta which means that
the fund is inversely correlated to the
market but given that markets trend up
with time it usually makes no sense to
invest in such a fund for an extended
period of time the average hedge fund
usually has a beta between 0 and 1. this
means that the fund is correlated to the
market but it will usually underperform
the market both to the upside and the
downside and with that being said take a
look at this graph comparing s p 500 and
hedge fund performance clearly hedge
funds basically never beat the s p 500
but focus on what happens when the s p
500 is posting losses between 2000 and
2002 the s p 500 lost 43 percent due to
the dot-com crash meanwhile the average
hedge fund didn't even have a single
negative year similarly in 2008 the s p
500 lost 37
while hedge funds only lost 22
now for most people it would have just
been better to hold the s p 500 through
such crashes given its superior overall
returns but this doesn't apply to
everyone for example let's go back to
jeff bezos
during the dot-com crash amazon stock
crashed 95 percent and given that 99
percent of his wealth was tied up with
amazon and he was back holding quite a
bit of amazon stock considering this
would it really have made sense for jeff
to invest the cash that he did have into
the s p 500 and back hold that as well
not really it would have made a lot more
sense for him to have invested that
money into a hedge fund and settled for
lower gains and more safety so clearly
it hedge funds don't have to beat the
market for them to be appealing in
certain situations with that being said
it really makes no sense to even compare
hedge fund returns with the s p 500
that's like comparing bonds with the s p
500 and then concluding that bond stock
given that they have lower yields it's
not that one is superior and the other
is inferior there are simply different
instruments that make sense in different
situations
if it doesn't make sense to compare
hedge fund performance with the s p 500
how should hedge funds be evaluated well
the answer is alpha every investment has
a risk profile which like hedge funds
are described by beta meanwhile alpha
describes how good your investment data
in relation to its beta value in other
words alpha is simply a way to measure
risk adjusted returns for example let's
say that in a given year the s p 500
returned 12 percent meanwhile you're a
fund manager who decides to invest in
apple you think that apple will
outperform the s p 500 but apple is a
bit riskier with a beta value of 1.2 now
let's say that apple ends up producing a
15 return which is 3 percent higher than
the s p500 by using this equation we can
determine that the alpha of this
investment was a positive 1.2 percent
meaning that it was a good investment in
this example apple stock outperformed
the s p 500 and our alpha was positive
but an investment does not need to
outperform the s p 500 for our alpha to
be positive for example instead of
investing in apple stock let's say we
buy an apple bond that yields five
percent per year while this investment
has a much lower return than the s p 500
it's also much safer and if its beta
value is low enough the upper bond could
still produce a positive alpha something
to keep in mind though is that this same
logic also works the other way around
just because you beat the market doesn't
mean that you'll have a positive alpha
for example if you produce a 100 return
but your beta is 10 your alpha won't be
looking that great alpha is the primary
benchmark institutions and the
billionaires look at when they invest in
a hedge fund and boasting a high alpha
is usually the number one goal of any
hedge fund ray dalio for example has an
entire group of funds that are called
pure alpha so next time you see a
headline that's trashing on hedge fund
returns don't be fooled into thinking
that these funds are garbage the only
way to really tell if they're garbage or
not is to look at their alpha
now that we've discussed the true goals
of hedge fund managers and how exactly
they achieve these goals let's talk
about their compensation the standard
fee structure amongst hedge funds is the
2 and 20 rule this means that fund
managers are paid 2 of the entire funds
assets under management every single
year regardless of how the fund performs
on top of this they receive 20 of any
profit they generate this means that
such funds have to grow over two percent
every single year just for their clients
to break even fortunately virtually all
hedge funds average a return of at least
two percent per year but this does
heavily dampen the net returns the
clients make not to mention it many of
the positions that hedge funds take are
short-term positions meaning that
clients have to pay short-term capital
gains taxes on these returns
some funds do offer lower fee structures
but basically all of the flagship funds
you hear about on the news use the
structure and the given that such funds
generally manage over 100 billion
dollars it's not surprising that fund
managers walk away with billions every
year in terms of the client's
perspective while it is true that these
fees are quite high you can't really
find hedging services for cheaper you
may be able to find better returns for
cheaper but you won't be able to find
hedging services for cheaper given the
hedging is quite work intensive analysts
on wall street generally work 100 to 120
hours every single week while this is
quite brutal especially in the early
days when you're not even making that
much money if you stick with it for five
to ten years it's quite reasonable to
earn seven figures every year
so if you're looking to make seven
figures when you're younger and you
don't want to start a business pursuing
wall street is likely the most
straightforward way to achieve it with
that being said though there is a dark
side to hedge funds in order to achieve
high alpha and minimize beta hedge funds
often use every trick you can think of
everything from market manipulation and
insider trading to pump and dumps and
securities fraud most of the time the
sac won't do anything about it but even
if they do for many hedge funds it's
just the cost of doing business and in
the end it just comes down to one
question do the ends justify the means
wall street tends to think that it does
all average people think that it doesn't
which side are you guys on comment that
down below also drop a like if you think
wall street needs to be held more
accountable and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one